il y a quelques années le cinéma d'art
et d'essai d'orléans crouler sous les
dettes et son avenir semblait bien
compromis jusqu'au jour où un ancien
cimetière cinéphile passionné a accepté
de relever le défi
bon on va dans les bureaux en fait ne
faut pas parler trop fort parce qu'il ya
une séance dans la salle 3 devant
laquelle on passe le bureau du patron
des carmes et au deuxième la semaine est
capital nous étions en plein festival de
cannes et à la fiche du cinéma d'art et
d'essai quatre films qui étaient en
compétition sur la croisette c'est baba
ce que ça va ça cadre que ça va marcher
quel est le fil qui a priori va le plus
marché sur les quatre alors à priori je
ne peux pas dire je m'abstiens de faire
ce genre de pronostic
parce que c'est le public et c'est ça
qui est génial et totalement
imprévisible
en revanche celui qui marche le mieux
pour l'instant c'est double à edwards
qui cartonne vraiment vraiment fait mon
cas
dans un cinéma le mercredi est toujours
très attendu c'est le jour des sorties
des films et forcément quand on a quatre
affiches présentent à cannes
les enjeux sont importants autour du
patron son équipe pour commenter les
premières entrées et coups de 16,7
démarrage modeste on va dire ya un mois
et étaient tout le temps à jouer à la
playstation avec karima qui peut enlever
tous les posters de ta chambre tu serais
d'accord qu'on d'esprit du corps une
fois par semaine tous les deux je peux
pas lire le coran
tu préfères le lien avec un les mêmes
qui est un menteur ce qui va être
intéressant à fin de la journée c'est ce
que les douleurs gloire douleur et
gloire et devant jeune ahmed derrière
ici les premières entrées sont scrutés
l'équipe du cinéma va aussi regarder les
critiques papier des films à la fiche en
s'appuyant notamment sur télérama il
aime beaucoup au jeune ahmed c'est un
ulysse souriant et ce taudis il dit
email idem pour stop by lm pour sybille
et idem pour l'eau les louches
on n'a pas le job de michel ferry ces
deux programmes et des films
une quinzaine chaque semaine 350 par an
ce matin là il va s'enfermer dans une
salle pour regarder lune de miel
c'est un des moments les plus à garder
et coup le film tout seul sans aucune
influence c'est très agréable
alors j'ai quand même pas besoin d'y
aller pour savoir que cette api atroce
oui 12 degrés on est quatorze et il ne
suffit pas d'être convaincu par le film
le plus dur reste à faire
négocié avec le distributeur sur une
semaine de 30 ans femme de quarante
heures j'en veux dire je passe 20 heures
au téléphone de négociation saisir tu
peux pas t'imaginer c'est que je passe
plus de temps à négocier film qui allait
voir ce qui est absurde
m
[Musique]